tells me i'm starting to look more and
more like axel rose
and uh
yeah
it is monday here in its grace and it's
time for another hashtag interrogate its
grace aka my q a but it has a super
fancy specific name that makes it unique
and different from other q and a's
also
no one else has axl rose on their q a
let's just drop the xrose thing because
they're all going to have to google
search it anyway
don't give them more tasks just only
give them the task of getting through
this video i went on my tumblr blog
gracehelbig.tumblr.com and i asked you
guys what kind of questions you wanted
me to answer and i'm going to answer
some of them right now not all of them
because then this series could never
continue
and then i'd have to actually use my
brain to come up with some unique ideas
for videos and huh
who wants that how do i make babysitting
fun for me i didn't really babysit very
much um
actually
not that i didn't babysit i was just
never
offered the chance to babysit and in
hindsight
oh yeah
adults must have instantly realized i
was not to be trusted with the life of
another thing younger than me
wow
oh man yeah no one ever asked me to
babysit for them
wow
i used to read the babysitter's club
books a lot so i guess because i read
them i thought that i had babysat
growing up but now thinking about it
no not at all
to be honest i've never changed a diaper
oh wow okay
really good start real light why do i
keep doing this to myself this sounds
like this is coming from a negative
place and
it also sounds like you've made a
pattern of negativity which happens to
the best of us
it's so much more familiar and
comfortable to live in a swell of misery
than to maybe step out of that and enjoy
some positivity so shake things up do
something different try something that
feels uncomfortable i gotta take my own
advice what did you do today i did so
much we've been shooting for hey usa
today and we shot some really great
stuff unfortunately i can't tell you
about any of that um but i will give you
some context clues police wrongfully
queues pop tarts how do i pick a seat on
the first day of school where you pick
or see is very um telling of your
personality as a human being people that
sit in the very back of the classroom
you can kind of tell that they're going
to peak really early in their life
they're going to peak when they're like
16 17 18 and then the rest of their
lives are going to be kind of sad people
that sit in the very front of the class
you might write them off as like nerds
geeks teachers pets etc
some of those people are probably going
to be very successful in their lives
maybe not in a social aspect but in an
academic professional aspect and then
there's some people that sit in the
middle i loved sitting in the middle
those to me are the people that
you never know that area is kind of like
a clearance rack why are you still not
using interrogate as your hashtag also
is it true you're only three-fourths a
human i've seen a lot of you ask me
about enterograce and i think it's
pretty great should i use it cause i
kind of like it and also am i
three-fourths of human
yeah because like one-fourth of me is
just totally
uncontrollably
repressed
and numb
it's like really cool what's the worst
joke you know a priest a rabbi and an
accountant walk into a bar the priest
and rabbi leave at a decent hour the
accountant because it hates his job so
much stays late into the night he gets
blackout drunk he ends up hooking up
with sheena the bar regular
she gets pregnant they go through with
the pregnancy sheena has the baby they
get married because they don't have
anything else they think that's what
they should do they get divorced two
years later and that baby grows up never
knowing what true love really is
gracesguidebook.com am i right correct
who will the opener be for the dc no
filter show so we don't have an opener
for the dc no filter show however
miss sarah weickel will be there doing
something in the show i can't tell you
exactly what and my brother tim helbig
will be doing something in our boston
show
and that's gonna be really exciting so
take that to the bank deposit it in the
fun account what job can i do when my
college degree is completely useless
what do you think about all the drama
surrounding the tcas
uh tcas i've learned is the teen choice
awards as far as i know it was a bunch
of
youtubers and interneters and
traditional actors and actresses that
got dressed up
went into a room
with cameras people on stage said things
people walked up touched surfboards
and then they went off stage and who
knows what happened after that i don't
understand the drama was there a nip
slip did five seconds of summer announce
that now they're gonna be six seconds of
summer because they have been inspired
by vine
did i miss that i don't know
okay don't forget to buy your tickets to
the no filter show we're coming to
boston dc austin los angeles and san
francisco and all of the ticket options
are down below yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah